ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are in what they call a
recession uh or
there's some debate about that because a
technical recession is two
quarters of negative growth which we
have not had but
uh you know the prices of things now the
gas the what do they call it the pain at
the pump god i love that pain at the
pump
the gas the inflation oh yeah
everything's going up everything's going
up food i mean what does it cost to feed
a fat
american family now like three thousand
dollars a week right
i mean it's the you just gotta you leave
with like buckets of
chocolate sauce for the kids it's so
much
[ __ ] money you you can't get ahead
and biden our president who's with us
this week he's back
he said uh biden says the us is not in a
recession despite
uh two consecutive quarters of a
shrinking economy but maybe there's some
some uh
there's some debate about whether it's
it's not negative growth or listen
it's it's it's hurting out there people
are
hurting out there but the job numbers
are good people are employed people are
scooping italian ice people are out
there working
so that in and of itself
is um a positive it's a positive thing
these are positives right there are
negatives
uh the gas being very high the food the
cost of uh you know
uh
flying if you can even fly they just
cancel everything now they just cancel
the flights
um but certain companies are being
creative with this and this is what i
want to tell you you have to be creative
to survive you're not going to be able
to get through this time unless you
survive airbnb has decided to start
trafficking women
and this is creative and it's a good
business it's controversial for sure but
airbnb you know it's a company that i
love and respect
great company uh they are now moving on
from just simply a hotel
uh service to a trafficking the women
that stay in the hotels
to to stay in the homes now airbnb is
saying let's traffic those women uh to
local traffickers
and that will make us a little bit on
the top they want a little extra on the
top
so this is an article here florida woman
alleges airbnb host in tulum attempted
to sex traffic her and friends i gotta
say smart right it's just smart so you
have the florida woman claims airbnb
host so they uh saint petersburg uh
woman amber jackson had the scare of her
life while checking into an airbnb in
tulum upon checking into the vacation
home jackson and her friends noticed
that there appeared to be blood on the
gate
the concierge team is shorter that it
was just paint so the airbnb concierge
team i don't know if you know this now
they will assure you that the body in
the uh house is a joke
like the airbnb concierge their job is
to just let you know that whatever
um you know whatever bodily fluid that
you find
on your rental property is supposed to
be there
that's uh part of the experience don't
worry about it
and uh they said it's just paint
and jackson uh didn't believe them amber
jackson said uh
i don't believe you once inside jackson
noticed that the keypads were not set
for the rooms this would allow anyone to
walk into the home and have access to
the belongings or the women themselves
after configuring the keypad herself
jackson was ready to head out and have
fun with her friends
okay however when they return they found
a strange man standing outside the home
claiming to be security
it's important to note that by this time
they had been there for a few days and
never saw security any other nights
jackson immediately contacted the
homeowner and concierge team
to verify the man's claims but nobody
answered for the entire night the women
guarded themselves with knives as they
slapped and checked out early the next
morning so this is now what
uh airbnb is doing airbnb has decided
that they need to start earning more
money how can you earn more money right
now trafficking your guests this is the
best way to do it
um
i mean it's it's great and they gave her
a refund of 67
and they didn't traffic her which may
say something about the way she looked
and the way her friends looked
they might not have been traffickable
but you have to be um you have to be
vigilant
and you have to be creative in this
economy if you're going to stay alive so
i applaud airbnb
uh from uh you know
like expanding their business model from
the uh general
uh staying in people's
dilapidated homes to
actually trafficking
uh vulnerable people who stay at their
property so that is a great by the way
hats off to everyone at airbnb
for making this change in your business
and when you report earnings i'm sure
that people will respond positively to
this
i think investors are gonna like it i
think people are gonna go well here's a
company realizing they're on the way out
because they are on the way out people
are getting sick of it hotels are back
and we've made this point before you
know the air the mystique of the airbnb
staying in someone else's house
vacationing in someone else's life going
oh my god do i want to live in
charleston let's see this is all over
now the pandemic has ended you're back
to your horrible life you've returned to
your horrible life you can no longer
pretend to live in 90 other lives during
the pandemic everybody had this fantasy
where they could go around the country
living in people's lives people putting
cowboy hats on and line dancing they had
no idea who they were and some of those
people bought property [ __ ] idiot
doing that okay some of those people had
a pulled pork sandwich and went yeah i
should have a mortgage with this um and
that's why you saw how you know uh
places like austin and nashville these
places that have just exploded and if
you're happy there god bless you um
and there's a ton of reasons to get out
of new york in la but the reality is you
have to choose a life now the pandemic
is over you must actually choose a life
for many many months there you did not
have to choose a life you could
literally week to week be a different
person every single week am i the bread
banking hoe
what am i
am i politically conscious ho
am i nashville boots hoe
am i [ __ ] austin texas taco ho
you have to choose what type of hoe i'm
not gendering this but you have to
choose what type of hoe you're going to
be now you must choose a life
you had your chance you had your time
and it was fun and it was entertaining
and i hope everybody enjoyed it and i
hope to god to use those couple of years
to really go out there and see what you
like and
that's what airbnb was for it was for
pretend oh we can all pretend to live in
each other's lives i wonder what it
feels like to be an artsy person in the
west village and i wonder what it feels
like to live in montana and look at
these mountains every day and what does
it feel like to be in palm springs it's
so hot and sexy but you eventually have
to choose a place you know you
eventually have to choose a life to live
and that is why airbnb which is just an
extension of people's madness um
and of course bachelorette parties and
uh bachelor parties and and things like
that which is i guess what airbnb is
let's get like is they tried to sway it
from that they try to steer it away from
the idea of like let's rent the house to
have a big party but that's really what
it should be you know because during the
pandemic it became like maybe i live in
maryland but what it really is
is you know what i mean like i like
crabs but now what it really is is going
back to
what it should be where you just rent a
house and you have a party you trash it
and someone dies
that is what airbnb always should have
been a party house like they should have
you should have three insurance policies
on your home and you should just have
like frat guys come in and [ __ ] just
pillage for 48 hours and hope to god
that nobody gets alcohol poisoning and
dies in the pool and they all give you
1300
for the privilege of partying in your
dump of the house in tucson arizona
that's what airbnb should be and that's
what it'll be now now that uh the
pandemic's over but now monkey pox is
here and people getting monkey pox uh in
orgies and monkey pox is a disease
that's affecting uh a gay man what a fun
way to be you know you got to come out
of the closet to just tell people you
have monkey pox
and you go oh but i'm not gay i don't
know how it happened but this is what
happens right people monkey park monkey
pox monkey parks monkey parks a new
discovery land community you know the
discoveryland people now you know many
of you don't know about the
discoveryland people because you're
you're just out of it but the
discoveryland people are the people that
are behind um the new development in la
quinta out in the desert of california
called the madison club where the
kardashians live uh the discovery land
properties and they have one in coeur
d'alene idaho and they have a bunch of
them and what they are
is a investment group uh that caters to
high net worth individuals that want to
have homes all over the country in
different desirable locations like the
mountains the beach
um you know some of them want to live in
the woods and they spend like two weeks
you know a year in each home and what
they do is they they entice a bunch of
celebrities to to buy these homes very
early on like leo they give a house to
leo dicaprio and then he goes to like
the local general store
and then the photographers photograph
him there and then all of a sudden all
these billionaires start going well i
want to live near leo i want to do that
so the discovery land people go well
he's got a house in the development act
now
and
all of these houses like you know
there's one house on sale in the madison
club right now it's 26 million dollars
so it's very very expensive um
and uh
they are
a
interesting you know when i like to keep
tabs on what the super rich are doing
what the what super wealthy people do uh
interests me especially as things um
unfold the way they are in our society
right
uh you go where are the people like
where are they going and they love these
discovery land they are secure they are
gated they are all around championship
golf courses
and this is where they want to live this
is where they don't want to live with
you
and nobody's airbnb being their homes uh
out in these places let's play
now this is from 2016. it's an old video
but let's play that because i'm hoping
that they give me one of these homes i
can't do any of the music it's
copyrighted but so here here's the type
of homes they have baker's bay in the
bahamas
yellowstone club in montana
perhaps you like gaza ranch coeur
d'alene
how about makina in maui hawaii
perhaps
the summit in summerlin nirvana would be
more to your liking
how about silo ridge
i love these names these sound like
like white supremacist compounds
the madison club in laquinta
beautiful
el dorado they kind of stole that one
huh yeah
so what they do is they just go around
the world creating these little narnias
[Music]
for people now why haven't they done one
in austin texas it seems like a
no-brainer to me to have a madison i
mean what is wrong with them are they
nuts
are they stupid
are these people daft
it seems to make so much sense to me to
put one of these places
in austin
texas which is let's get the weather up
right now what is the weather in austin
texas
this is when folks i got to be honest
with you california you can hate it and
and and i'm not saying you shouldn't but
the climate
we really are winning climate right now
austin texas 100 degrees uh humidity 41
yeah and it's been that way for what
like forever yeah and it'll go up to 103
by wednesday why doesn't the madison
like why doesn't um the people behind
the discovery land properties build a
luxury because what they should do is
build a luxury compound in austin texas
where every single house has its own
podcast studio and comedy club
every house
so every like 15 000 square foot house
has a comedy club in it where rich
psychopaths can pretend to be comedians
and why not
and do podcast it's a great idea because
that's you know
part of the appeal
of austin at the moment right
is the idea that you've got something to
say
so let's why not
don't billionaires have things to say oh
yeah i think it's a great idea i think
it's a great idea and i am
ready to support it now
what are you
uh
doing in this economy to safeguard
yourself and your family
uh i have a bookie
you are betting now and you are gambling
is this true a little bit but not much
but but you're such a degenerate addict
do you not worry that this behavior will
metastasize into a real problem it might
but i'm keeping a safeguard on what is
it for you like the thrill it's yeah it
heightens the experience of what life of
baseball
and you bet how much money uh sometimes
i'll butt up to like 400 on a game but
this is a real problem
it's kind of insane i'm doing it yeah no
it's crap but are you winning i am
winning i am winning all the time enough
well i'm i'm up i'm up my i bet units
you bet units i'm up units who is this
bookie uh he's just a guy i met through
our realtor friend remember the guy with
the hat
our
loser realtor friend
introduced you to a bookie who you're
now betting on baseball games with he's
like a trust fund kid and he just like
is my bookie
because you're not allowed to gamble in
california
arrest him
this is an admission of guilt come into
the studio take him away in cuffs you
will hear nothing from me i hope they do
arrest you and i hope they save your
life
because you deserve to be in jail water
is amazing it's a coffee alternative
with four optogenetic mushrooms and
ayurvedic herbs with one seventh of the
caffeine is a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety cheaters and
crash of coffee each ingredient was
added for a purpose cacao and chai from
mood and a micro dose of caffeine lines
made for alertness cordyceps to help
physical performance chagas and rishi to
support your immune system turmeric for
soreness and cinnamon for antioxidants
we love it mud water is a whole30
approved usda organic non-gmo
gluten-free vegan kosher certified
mudwater has launched their new
evening ritual the rest blend a
non-caffeinated tea that you love
that promotes relaxation and rest
because the best morning rich will start
the night before go to
mudwater.com that's
mudwtr.com support the show and use the
code tim for five dollars off mud water
is great especially if you're sick of
coffee
i phased out coffee a while ago we're
switching to mud water keeps us alert
awake our brains are good we can do the
show it's really great go to
mudwater.com that's m-u-d-w-t-r.com
tim i'm telling you you get five dollars
off your first shipment you will not
regret it i like to drink it with a
little uh little oat milk
yeah oh honey oh well i
well it's great because the coffee hurts
your stomach but this stuff the taste is
better it doesn't hurt yourself i'll
tell you what i did the first time i had
mud water
i
was not even like
i was feeling so sad
and i had mud water for the first time
and i was walking around my neighborhood
and i saw
a robbery
a man was robbing a woman of her
pocketbook
now
that's horrible it's not funny
if i didn't have that mud water i don't
know what i would have done
but i had drank the mud water
i went up to the man
and i killed him
with my bare hands i
grabbed his head
and i dug my fingers in his eyes really
deep to where they were about to pop out
of his skull
and i bashed his head on the ground
until it was just blood so much blood i
couldn't even see it and then
i gave the woman back her pocketbook
mudwater.com tim dillon that's
mudwtr.com
tim dylan
take your summer adventure to the next
level the bespoke post in a new seasonal
lineup of must-have box of awesome
collections bespoke post partners with
small businesses and emerging brands and
you know i love this you know here's
what you do you give somebody box of
awesome you take a quiz see what they're
into you give them one box every month
okay it's got about 70 worth of stuff
you spend 40
on it it is great to send somebody who
you might not see in a while somebody
who moved going to college to get all
this cool stuff no matter what they're
into box of awesome does all this you
know does the gift giving for you but
you still give the gift how cool is that
can i say something they just sent me
yes they sent me a couple uh whiskey
tumblers and they sent me this cool
travel bag but you can have it if you
want it i don't want it okay all i wanna
use it
all i want is world peace
with each box of awesome you're
supporting small businesses 90 of
everything that comes in the box of
awesome is from a small up-and-coming
brand it's free to sign up and you can
skip a month or cancel any time i'm
telling you it's really great
what it what what are you i love it all
right so far i have been a knife now i
have a bag they sent me a box of
pancakes yeah yeah those are good yeah i
mean they don't they know they're not
screwing around
get 20 off your first monthly buck and
i'm dead serious you know i gave this to
a friend of mine and he loves it because
every month they give him something else
like one month they give him like cool
stuff like cool bottle openers and stuff
for the drinking he's making moonshine
you know and the next yeah and the next
month they they have
you know different kinds of outdoorsman
stuff for him like camping stuff because
he likes going camping he's a real man
you know go and they give him bear spray
in one of them because sometimes bears
try to get them
um
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com and
enter the code tim dillon at checkout
that's box of awesome.com code tim
dillon for 20
off your first box box of awesome.com
code tim dillon
take the quiz at box of awesome.com
folks do it now what else is going on
here in this world how are we going to
survive this recession i don't know i
don't know i don't know
so now people are mad at zelinski just
because he did a cover shoot of vogue
magazine yeah can you not is the is the
i mean
is he not allowed to feel hot this is a
real question
is this guy not the entire reason
that anyone cares about the ukraine is
because zelensky is good looking this is
true
no one cares about the uk you know it's
a hollywood narrative him and his wife
the ukraine is full of white people many
of them are like
far right wing
a lot of them are uncomfortably close to
nazi-ish
it is absolutely a country that no one
would care about in amer like the types
of people that care about it wouldn't
care about it unless there was an angle
and part of the angle is that the young
attractive leader of the ukraine is so
eloquent and passionate about his
country so he does a photo shoot in
vogue
and people are angry with him
people are angry that he has
dared to be attractive which is the only
this is being first lady is not a role
elena zelenska ever wanted to play
i like being backstage she says it
suited me
she said to vogue i love anyone with a
photoshoot in vogue going i like to be
backstage this whole thing's an accident
she said the vogue in a wide-ranging
interview conducted in person in keith
moving into the limelight was quite
difficult for me
she and ukrainian president vladimir
zelinski met in high school started
dating at university and had a full life
in the entertainment world before
zielinski won the presidency in 2019
protective of their family life she had
wanted uh him to run but like so many of
her fellow ukrainians in this war
zelinska has risen to the occasion with
grace and grit i'm trying to do my best
for vogue special digital cover story
selinska and her husband ukrainian
president vladimir zelinski spoke about
life in wartime their marriage and like
by the way
how about we just stick with life in
wartime why in god's name are we asking
them about their marriage it seems a
little crazy to me they're like they're
speaking about life and wartime and
their marriage
what how about just the wartime
so if you notice this picture one of my
favorites
a very glamorous mrs zielinski is posing
in front of i believe the wreckage
of a plane that's what it appears it
appears to be
so she's on the front lines here she's
in the the wreckage of a plane and she's
doing this kind of sexy
you know but distressed
thing now if you've ever done a photo
shoot now here's the deal
if you've ever done a photo shoot or
you've ever been to a photo shoot you
know how incredibly bad taste this is
because you have to do this multiple
they didn't just get these shots this
isn't like an accident they have to do
this multiple times they have to get the
lighting right they have to hit you from
multiple angles you know they have to go
just give me stoic
just give me set just just stone face
you know realize the gravity of the
moment to the you know just kind of tilt
your head and perfect right there right
there boom snap snap snap so when you
realize how insane because it doesn't
seem insane when you just sit back and
go okay the vogue's a huge publication
but then when you realize the actual
nuts and bolts of having to do
a
um i hate my headphones this way they're
bothering me uh
when you when you realize the nuts and
bolts of having to do an actual
photo shoot
and what it entails
during uh
wartime it does seem insane um and
people are angry um somebody tweeted
here uh avi yemeni tweeted i respected
zelinski at the beginning of the war
when we were flooded with photos of the
ukrainian president on the front line of
tactical gear turns out photos were
faked
and
an act like the man himself now posing
for a vote were those photos faked of
him out there in the thing
uh who knows it's hard to know we don't
know i'm sure some of them were yeah but
stick with that because the vogue is
confusing people
it's confusing people
um
but he's gonna they're gonna do a markle
thing right oh yeah they're coming over
here oh yeah they're on their way
they are calling they are talking to the
realtors from selling sunset right now
they are on their way to los angeles
they are headed for the big leagues
they're coming to hollywood like meghan
markle and harry the zielinskis are
coming to hollywood they want to be
stars they don't want to run that [ __ ]
they don't care about it
now they've got a taste in a big life
yeah baby what are you gonna do eat uh
what are they eating ukraine i don't
even know but you're gonna stew
you're gonna eat that
don't you you have a chance now
ben stiller tells zilinski's my hero he
didn't know who he was
a couple of months ago so he's meeting
with people because he's a production
company right who i've been of course
listen 100
the zelinski's are coming and they are
going to start producing stuff and it's
and i'm telling you right now
some of it might be good
because this is a real
production this whole thing has been a
production from the beginning till now
this is a production and i think they're
going to get quite tired of this war
thing they've used it and by the way
kudos to them for building a brand
listen no i'm dead see ya i am 100
serious about all of this
they were [ __ ] smart
to use this to build a [ __ ]
international
lifestyle brand
which is what they're doing
when you have an opportunity seize it
seize it
don't let it pass you by rahm emanuel
said never let a good crisis go to waste
zilinski and his wife late at night
pillow talk they're going hey
hey
we are the talk of the town not this
town
hollywood they love us they love us in
new york
they love us in london we're big
we've got something here we've got books
we've got documentaries we got a [ __ ]
deal
we we were the president of [ __ ] country
no one gives a [ __ ] of it nobody knew
what it was
nobody knew what it was
all of a sudden putin knocked some of it
off and we're in the game big time we're
heroes
now we just got to negotiate some little
[ __ ] settlement that allows us to
emerge victorious and then we just boom
we're in montecito by the pool
and it's smart it's [ __ ]
shrewd and anyone who's angry at it [ __ ]
you
he's they're ready
to [ __ ] enjoy the spoils
it's time to enjoy the spoils now
they've pretended they faked this thing
for long enough now with the fake flak
jacket in the helmet
how many photo shoots he did it he get
listen he told apparently the russians
aren't going to leave they don't care
how many of their people die they don't
give a [ __ ] about any of it they will
bankrupt themselves they are never
leaving they want this like [ __ ] factory
in dunbas or whatever they will not
leave until they have this like [ __ ]
factory in that dumb tap they will they
don't care about anything
they want this place they want it
apparently they are real committed it
was not a flash in the pan thing for
them and zelinski's now starting to
really i think in the ukraine they're
starting to realize this they're like
the only way out of this is through
fame and fortune
because i'm not trying to die on the
vogue photo shoot says i am not trying
to die on the battlefield i know that's
how i presented it earlier i presented
it as if i was willing to die with the
townspeople on the be that is not what
i'm willing to do anymore i i am
thinking differently i'm thinking
differently i'm speaking to netflix
they don't have a lot of money but with
little they have they're giving to me
and a tiny little bit to tim dillon to
put a special there
august 16th i believe
but this is where he's now finally doing
the pivot that needs to be done i
applaud him for his p you try it's
enough with this enough with this
nonsense you're not dying for your
people he was never that type of guy
he was he's too smart for that
and he doesn't have that you know honor
and he's not honor bound but
he's so he's a modern leader and modern
leaders run
when the going gets tough modern leaders
leave and get deals at streaming
services and whine about how badly they
were treated
you need to sit on the couch with oprah
and start crying and talk about how hard
your marriage is
like you didn't vote that's what a
modern leader does
modern leaders from him the trump to but
none of these people
are going to go down with the ship
they've created no they're not going to
go down with the ship
but in the beginning it was kind of that
brilliant idea that he might that
brilliant idea you're like oh my god
wait what
this guy
like imagine one of our leaders doing
that it was it's it's
unimaginable
to think about any of them on the front
lines of anything well apparently he
wasn't either but
we thought he would well it was because
he marketed it like he was he probably
visited some true remember george w bush
said thanksgiving here's the turkey in
iraq he went and brought them a turkey
that's what modern leaders do it's a
photo op they bring the people that are
about to be slaughtered to turkey and
say let's eat turkey together while you
fight this quagmire that's what
modern leaders do they're not on the
battlefield that's great here he is yeah
this is
president bush with the turkey
this is a modern leader and he's got the
army jacket on same thing
yeah yeah yeah there he is
looks good
so this is what modern leaders do by the
way god bless them i'm proud of
zielinski for stopping the nonsense i
think his agent caldman went cut the
[ __ ] now
it's enough already well how long are
you gonna do this
get out of that country
and how is the ukraine war going by the
way i mean we no one cares anymore but i
imagine it's still happening let's see
and it saddens me and i hope it's i hope
it you know whatever
i mean i don't know anymore all i know
is that the russians are willing to stay
there for a century
so none of this horse race stuff matters
it would only matter if the russians
cared a little bit about leed they just
don't want to leave right they're not
going to leave
they just will not go they're going to
keep coming back
well
sorry
but
yeah so now brittany griner this uh
a
basketball player who went to russia to
supplement her income
uh
and smoked uh what did they find out
hashish yeah but it's the vape pin the
vape pen with a hashish oil so they say
and now we are trading her for a russian
arms dealer that's a even trade huh wnba
member for a russian arms dealer but
whatever we got to get her back she's an
american
we don't want her to come back like otto
warmbier remember him that college
student he went to north korea
supposedly he stole a flag like as a
little prank and then his parents you
know he was stuck there and then finally
his parents were like oh he's home it's
great and then like literally his sister
went on the plane saw the condition he
was in and ran off the plane screaming
it was horrible it was horrible i mean
they
rearranged his teeth and scrambled his
brain over there in north korea it was
very bad so you don't want grinder to
come back like that you want her to come
back and uh play in the uh wnba but
again and i said this on the bonus
episode if we bail you out if we then
enough don't say anything other than
like i want you to be candace owens
level patriotic if we trade a russian
arms dealer for you that's all that's
all i'm asking if we trade a russian
arms dealer for you and you come back
just be candace owens level patriotic i
mean where it's annoying like the first
pose should be red white and blue in an
all red white and blue thing singing the
national anthem like i'm i'm just
telling you
just be grateful you're in a foreign
country smoking hash nobody has to get
you
but if this corpse biden arranges to get
you somehow
by
trading this whatever high-value russian
guy or supposedly
just be happy about it right just be
enjoy it and don't be like
you know don't don't come back and you
know
just don't just be happy that's all i'm
saying
don't don't be negative in any
aspect if you've just been brought back
from russia
i want that to be part of the deal if
the biden administration was smart part
of the deal would be we're bringing you
back on the
on the
um condition
that you are relentlessly positive about
our country
no matter what from here on out you must
be
relentlessly positive about the united
states of america even in the face of
mounting evidence to the contrary you
must be
the most positive person ever why
because we bailed you out of a russian
jail
whilst at war kind of with them
during a cold war we bailed you out
that's amazing
like you can't come back
and start
being like how many women were nominated
for best director don't
don't even start with that now
if you come back and start that you
gotta go to russia again
you can't come back and have any
problems
you just have to chill
if you come back you gotta go you gotta
chill
the wife too
and the wife
if you go on oprah you gotta go you know
what amazes me how great our country is
that's all you do if we trade this
[ __ ] character from die hard so that
you can come back to america and play a
sport no one watches you must at least
be grateful you must at least be
grateful for this i'm telling you
this must at least be something that
warms your heart enough where you cannot
literally complain about anything
you can't
so this economy what else how are people
doing it out there are people
figuring it out californians and other
mexicans are flooding mexico city and
the locals don't like it well too bad
it works both ways
yeah white [ __ ] are coming to your
[ __ ] town that's right you people
come here and work hard we go there and
don't work
that's right
hey man if you want it to be a big open
world you're gonna have to deal with it
occasionally you send over some people
that aren't great and we're gonna send
over some people that aren't great and
that's the way it works so the [ __ ] what
grow up
mexico has long been the top foreign
travel destination for americans it's
bountiful beaches and picturesque
pueblos luring tens of millions of u.s
visitors annually but in recent years a
growing number of tourists and remote
workers hailing from brooklyn new york
silicon valley and points in between
oh yeah baby have flooded the nation's
capital and left ascent of a new wave
imperialism will you stop
the la times
will you stop
a new wave of imperialism because what
they went there and got drunk
listen to this at lardo a mediterranean
restaurant where on any given night
three quarters of the tables are filled
with foreigners a mexican man in a
well-cut suit recently took a seat at
the bar gazed at the english language
menu before him inside as he handed it
back a menu in spanish please this is
what people in america say about
mexicans
they say i don't want to look at things
in spanish and all of a sudden we we say
that they're nazi racist pieces of [ __ ]
and then the l.a times is an article
where a mexican guy goes hey can i have
something in my native tongue and they
go these white pieces of [ __ ] going to
order [ __ ] tacos in mexico
what are we doing here do you want a
global world or not
the la times is like the new york times
except everyone like the new york times
is wrong but at least the people that
worked there went to schools
like the la times is like these are the
dumbest p there are entire groups of
people at the la times who's like beat
is
going around a comedy store with a black
light trying to find crystally a semen
now
that's a job
now listen
what is insane about this is they're
saying that i'm not saying that white
people aren't annoying when they travel
they're annoying we went to london you
know we go to this great restaurant
dinner by huston blumenthal maybe one of
the best restaurants we've ever been
in the uh in the mandarin oriental hotel
our favorite hotel i think we've ever
been to and we're sitting there and they
give you the option of hearing about all
the different courses they go so nice
when we bring you the courses that all
date back to like the 15th century or
whatever would you like us to tell you
about them and tell you how the chef
came out and of course we go short you
tell us whatever you want to tell us
um
but
the american couple's sitting next to us
or they go would you like to hear about
that and they go no but do you have any
ketchup so we know we are well aware of
how annoying and grotesque americans can
be when they're abroad but to to say
that it's imperialism
uh because a couple of [ __ ] are
drinking margaritas is stupid and insane
and i can't even believe that the la
times wrote this article not realizing
how crazy it seems to anyone let's keep
reading this here
um recently expletive lace posters
appeared around the town new to the city
question mark working remotely question
mark they read in english you are a
[ __ ] plague and the locals [ __ ]
hate you leave
now how would that work if we put those
up in places of border towns around
america would that be good
please don't read one of the kinder
replies the city is becoming more and
more expensive every day in part because
of people like you and you don't even
realize or care about it
hugo van der moyer 31 a video game
designer who grew up in florida and
namibia
ambient namibia
has spent the last several months
working remotely from mexico city
montreal and bogota colombia i said he
understands why locals are vexed by the
growing population of digital nomads
people i guess they're just you know
they work online and they can kind of
live anywhere um
quote there's a distinction between
people who want to learn about the place
they are in and those who just like it
because it's cheap
i've met a number of people who don't
really care that they're in mexico they
care that it's well isn't it can this
not be said for america
can it not be said when people come to
america there's a distinction between
why is the nintendo switch right here
this doesn't this is what ray i'm sorry
ray comp gave me that
um but it doesn't seem professional
but can't this be said about america
here that there's some people that are
coming to america because they want
america uh they like america and they
want them and there's just a lot of
other people that are coming to america
because it's an economic opportunity
can't that be said about america what a
weird article
that the la times writes
despite growing tensions mexico city is
not paris where an american stumbling
over french in a boulangerie will get a
dose of hostility along with her
croissants it's not berlin or barcelona
where locals in recent years have
mounted major protests over excessive
tourism and the gobbling up of urban
properties by global investment firms
the vast majority of people in this
crowded colorful metropolis are
unwaveringly kind and patient with
international visitors who are in their
first four months of this year spent 851
million on hotels alone so what guys
guys
listen
hey
i don't know what to tell you people are
spending money they're going to i'm not
going to mexico city and starting
problems but people are going there
they like it it's pretty it's cheap
they spent over uh just about a billion
dollars
on hotels four months yeah yeah in four
months
yeah there's growing pains
there's growing pains in mexico same
with this growing pains in america when
you assimilate tens of millions of
people into a culture there's growing
pains
i don't understand i mean it's just such
a crazy article
and by the way why i think this article
is funny is because every mention
that
like immigration
might have
some downsides or might be
have some difficulties there might be
some challenges associated with
immigration
people
at the la times write that you are a
crazy like
nazi
if you
even
pose the question
um
what are some of the challenges with
immigration but they write an article
the other way
where they are completely understanding
of the difficulties that people in
mexico are having with an influx of
americans
so it's just very strange to me it's odd
to me yeah this stuff's hard
it doesn't mean that there's not people
overreacting on both sides but this [ __ ]
is hard
he goes like this
after his revelations at this cafe
bustos uploaded a video of his popular
tic toc account complaining that the
influx of foreigners in mexico city
quote stinks of modern colonialism
nearly 2 000 people posted comments in
agreement his critique is multi-layered
and space speaks to generations of
injustices
there's the problem of newcomers quote
indifference as to how their actions are
affecting locals
he also believes that americans many of
whom are white are reinforcing the
city's pervasive
if frequently
if infrequently discussed caste system
so the mexican caste system
is being somehow bolstered by the white
people that are going there this is why
people's brains have been uh broken
and this is why
you see
uh
people completely tuning out
mainstream sources of news
um
because this is written with like no
irony
people don't understand it i mean it's
kind of a funny article
where mexicans are complaining about
american immigration
it's kind of a funny article and they're
saying a lot of the similar things just
saying i want the menus in english
please put the menus in english people
come to this country because it's cheap
they don't really care about these are
the exact
same
things said by people in america that
are often critical of mexican
immigration into the u.s so it's just
very interesting now does this article
at any point acknowledge that probably
not
uh oh here we go here's bustos chimed in
on it
yeah
mexico's classes and racist
people with white skin are given
preference now if a local wants to go to
a restaurant or club they don't just
have to compete with rich white mexicans
but with foreigners too i thought he was
saying the other way right
i mean hey man
i you know
at a certain point
this is what everybody wants no
you want this globalized world
i mean you're gonna get some problems
right
like
you might get some problems
i want to bring a bunch of white people
now down to mexico city
and do a concert of traditional mexican
music
you know
like a bunch of
people
real white
like midwestern white people to go down
and
sing traditional mexican folk songs
in like poorly pronounced
in like a southern twang like hi y'all
we're singing folk songs from mexico
um
sarah lupton are 35 year olds from north
carolina who came to mexico city last
year as soon as she got her second
coveted vaccination said she fell in
love with the quote romantic yet gritty
aesthetic she ended up well this is what
they did in bushwick this is what they
do all the all over the place she ended
up selling her video production company
and relocating her in january with her
shih tzu now she's learning spanish
applying for residency and exploring a
new path as life and career coach
can you imagine sarah like hi
i'm your career coach
hi what's your name luz
hi
i'm sarah lupton i'm a career coach i
grew up in larchmont new york
my father worked at a bank and my mother
sat in the kitchen and took pills
i went to nyu film school because i
wanted to make a great romantic movie
something that i'd never really
experienced i had a video production
company that my father funded
we actually ended up just making videos
uh for people's dogs but it had enough
value upon selling it i came here and
bought what is this called a casita
now i'm here
i'm learning your language and i'm
telling you how to live
lose
you're telling me that you have problems
your brother became involved in the drug
trade and he got his hand chopped off
you feel guilty because you don't have
enough money to feed your children lose
can i introduce you to the concept of
manifesting
manifesting
do you meditate
do you ever sit down lose and visualize
where you would like to be in five years
i think you're doing yourself a great
disservice
now who showed up to your house in the
middle of the night
i understand that's distressing
but i think what you really have to
focus on is you i've heard a lot about
your brother and your children and these
strange men who come to your house in
the middle of the night asking where
your brother is and threatening to kill
you what i haven't heard about luz is
you
who is lose
who do you want to be
what makes you happy
what makes you cry do you ever just take
a walk in the rain
do you ever just drink white wine and
walk it because in larchmont we had like
three acres it was too much
you know my mother and my father used to
always argue about it because he left
you know the edges of the property a
little rough but i would wander out in
the loose and it would be like the
secret garden and you know after the
rain you would see the butterflies lose
and they were so beautiful and i would
steal a little bit of my mother's wine
she always noticed
and i just walk around the garden the
rough edges of our manicure property in
larchmont and i would just feel like
alice in wonderland
lose
do you ever consider doing that
because i'm telling you right now
i think the answer to your problem lies
in reconnecting with you
what did the men say they were going to
do to you well that is horrible
that's absolutely heartless i'm not even
going to repeat that
it that doesn't even seem anatomically
possible
oh you've seen it one of your friends it
was done too
oh my god
and where did they leave the body in the
town square
well lose you can't live in the past
you have to live in the future
so lose
this session with seventy dollars
i mean can you imagine that well see
this is now this is the next level
listen a bunch of white people and you
gotta communicate with them in english
to feed them is one thing
moving to a country like mexico
as a white check
who's probably got a little scratch
and becoming a life coach which is a
career coach which is a
fake job
here
it's fake here
let alone
in mexico like going in mexico
mexico
it is crazy
laura rodwell 40 also moved down in
january after spending several months
here last year and by the way this is
why i do feel bad for mexico the
mexicans that are coming here largely
are just very hardworking people we are
sending our biggest pieces of [ __ ] there
we are sending like tech people that are
like bored
and want to go to a foreign country
because like they they have hollow lives
and they want to go somewhere else and
they can work remotely we are sending
the worst people in the world there
listen to this lauren rodwell 40 also
moved down in january after spending
several months here last year a marketer
who works at a tech job that is remote
she was tired of living in san francisco
where every conversation began with
quote what do you do
i like being in vibrant cities that have
multiple cultures that mix well
where there's good food and good energy
and dancing and art
it reminds me
of being in a more friendly more clean
at times brooklyn
man here's the deal and people are going
to get upset with me for saying this if
the mexicans really want to stop this
they just have to start raping and
killing them
and and i don't even know if that would
stop it
but
you know
i don't know
oh rodwell's black still doesn't matter
oh okay get out of mexico
hmm
interesting i i i'm just i understand
that the influx of tech people is uh uh
trying at times but i don't know what to
tell you you know this is what happens
you have a global world people from all
over the place go and you know they
bother you that's what globalism is
people all over the world travel and
bother you and unfortunately make it
harder for you to live
that is what it is and there are some
benefits to that too you get a cheap
shirt and look good food
ordering all your summer essentials with
desp debt
with dasha necrosilva
ordering all your summer essentials with
dasha nekrosova kidding doordash is a
great way to get everything you need and
during the summer of dash pass you can
save money and access members-only
offers that will help you feel easy and
breezy all season long summer is in full
swing and celebrations begin during the
summer of dash pass by doordash with
weekly members only benefits and new
items released every week you can shine
bright and feel cool
all season long do you order from
doordash but you don't want to pay
delivery fees well dreams do come true
during the summer of dash pass
um you don't have to how about that just
join and you get zero delivery fees all
year round plus a lot of other member
offers say hello to summer savings
with your dash pass by doordash
membership you can save an average of
four to five dollars on every order you
place for delivery or pickup that means
on average cash pass pays for itself
when you order just twice a month with
members only offers and items dropping
every week you'll have everything you
need to make the most out of summer
right
at your
finger tips shine bright during door
dashes summer of dash pass get 50 off
your first order and up to 15 value use
promo code tim dillon to check out when
you spend 12 or more that's 50 off your
first order up to 15 value when you sign
up for doordash during the summer of
dash pass using promo code tim dillon
don't forget that that's tim dillon for
50 off your first order up to 15 value
dashbes benefits only on eligible orders
that meet the minimum subtotal terms
apply and we'll we'll probably use it
right after this i use it all the time
use it all the time
you broke the cactus that's hilarious
we love steve we'll do it let's go to
his youtube channel what is he doing
right now he's a really good friend of
ours
he helps a lot of people
he's a the breakout star of the nelk
boys
uh and you got to go to his youtube
channel at
steve will do it he has a new video
called my girlfriend
i don't think it's real though nothing i
don't know if any of it is real on
youtube steve is a trained professional
do not attempt anything you see on this
page like having a girlfriend
okay let's see okay i don't know what
he's doing but let's
uh
he's so crazy he messages me that i'm
racist
well you are
he does you're not a rookie he knows
oh
[ __ ]
somewhere
it was either here or uh
[Music]
they look like they have a good time
they have a good time you know attack it
differently
that's his crosstalk that's pretty much
can you please
go to the other place and grab me a
phone charger please while i film this
outro
okay so this video
i was [ __ ] with celina so i want to
continue to [ __ ] with her
and make a video out of this the title
of this video has now changed from i'm
dating a beautiful black stripper to
something along the lines of me fake
proposing to selena okay selena wants to
get married right high-value men but i'm
gonna say whatever i gotta say it's
gonna be real and then i'm gonna go and
say selena smith
check out the new ring i got myself
like check out the new ring i got myself
instead of will you marry me and then my
friends over at white carrot they're
gonna give her some grill dude imagine
like carlin had somehow lived
and like he was like you got the
youtubes and the snapchats
you get youtube snapchat
yeah the snapchats and instagram you got
the reels and the like how crazy it's a
big algorithm and you ain't in it it's a
big algorithm and you ain't it
you and i ain't in
[Laughter]
yeah
wow [ __ ] you
that is just rude
you were like crying
[Music]
i think these people know that like none
of their lot like nothing that ever
happens is real like she's eating dinner
on a pool table yeah and he's like
pretending to propose i think they all
know
that everything that can happen like
like every single video where like you
know he'll be like listen i have cancer
or i'm gonna propose or
like nothing's real so i think these
people just
tana mojo did a video once with jake
paul where she goes i'm having your baby
really and she's like no and then all
the cameras come out like oh no they
just do stuff like that this is what
they do they're just committed but you
got to visit steve we'll do it um over
on the youtube channel he's uh
he's really taking off
you know he is he's taking off and he
has a couple channels too
oh he's got a bunch yeah he has a steve
will do it too and all that stuff
he's got a lot they're interesting
people i got to do their podcast i keep
telling them i'd covered and then i can
do it and the whole thing but we gotta
we will get back to that
um
let's support this guy because he's uh
you know
that's the best photo of him by the way
in the sombrero yeah i know it's kind of
hilarious he's just culturally
appropriating on his feet he's just like
he looks so happy he looks so happy with
like the big bottle of alcohol
yeah i mean he's done things that are
like like defy
science
like when he like the drinking and
everything that he's done it's crazy
steve will do it go visit him thank you
um what else before we get out of here
come see me by the way if you have not
bought tickets for wise guys comedy club
in salt lake city good mormons out there
please come and see me we'd really
appreciate that
so cool west hampton beach doing a live
podcast myself benjamin ray comp at the
west hampton pack uh special out on
netflix august 16th
probably have a trailer and a um
a
little promotion coming out about that
uh
soon this is fun surviving an active
shooter l.a county sheriff this is great
uh
an active shooter is part of american
life
um i don't even know if it's a bad part
it's just something
i don't even think you have to look at
it negatively it's a great time for you
to show your ingenuity and your skill
set but this video surviving an active
shooter uh this is from 2015
because we've had this problem for a
minute
um
let's play a little bit of this okay now
where did this go out to who who got
this video so this is the la county
sheriff's made this but this has been
making the rounds on twitter as this
here which i haven't been able to find
because companies play it for people
when they get hired now at places
watching active shooter training for
work yeah [ __ ] is insane yeah and it's
it's just like this guy
just like just going ape [ __ ] on people
in the in the place and like everybody
watches this before you work at sears
part of an american
workplace yeah
so somebody taking a gun out of their
bag
in the middle of the day
and blowing people's heads off is part
of an american workplace if you don't
like it move to mexico city
like any other turned tragic today when
an employee opened fire on his
supervisor and fellow co-workers
students parents they turned the
comments off for this obviously after a
bloody rest yeah i would imagine
details are just coming in but we're
being told that a heavily armed gunman
opened fire this evening at the mall
food court behind me there's no official
word i'll skip forward here here we go
this is for the people to know how to
survive in any situation you got to get
some sleep you're looking like a vampire
you sleep you ain't got no babies at
home keeping you up
what the hell
oh sam again we've tried i'm sorry
we're gonna have to let you go
[Music]
active shooter killings are a tragedy
what it is predictable reality and how
much blood and so much blood that's so
much by the way let's go back to that
that is so much blood
tragic
so much blood she goes listen we're
gonna have to let you go
we're gonna have to let you go and then
he just blows her head off
i was like [ __ ] but i want to work at
this warehouse
you're telling me i can't work at this
warehouse
he just goes out like it's just 2006 the
us has averaged an active shooter event
with four or more deaths
every 2.9 months
even though the number of active shooter
events has been increasing
your odds of being involved in one are
still very slim that's nice but just
like fire drills and earthquake
preparedness making a plan in advance
can make all the difference
yeah but lizards live in tanks
lizards live in tanks i love this like
l.a i love these like
like these like weird the dialogue that
they write in between
the active shooter the guy with the baby
one guy's like you ain't got babies
keeping you up and then this girl walks
in and she goes lizards live in tanks
what is strange
it's odd
and all these people are in la like
wanting to be actors they're they're all
of course i mean you got to get a gig
a senseless attack the why doesn't
matter hey
hey buddy
[Music]
what matters is surviving okay how on
average 20 stop telling us we know how
do i survive
how do i do it killers usually choose
their victims at random they offer easy
targets that's not comforting so the
harder you are to see or to hit the
safer you are smart
smart
[Music]
when an attack starts if you can find a
way out of the location do so
get out
smart
if you stay calm and think clearly even
in the middle of a life and death event
you improve your chances of making it
out
visualize your movements in advance what
are we gonna do look at me look at me i
can get us out stay behind me stay now
use cover something that will stop a
bullet and concealment something that at
least keeps you out of sight use cover
something that would stop a bullet
use cover
something that would stop a bullet okay
245 esv 417
town center i love just like the 901
guys so routine he's like they're
shooting up the mall again
hey we have hello is anyone working out
there yeah we've got another shooting at
the mall food court um
you know
what else you want me to tell you it's
america
it's wearing a face mask possible body
armor
use any available means to get out
including emergency exits or windows
most restaurants and retail locations
will also have exits in the back through
kitchens or stock rooms how great would
it be to see a guy just like following
them through that just shooting at them
you're not getting away
this part's crazy here with
a second
even in the best cases police are
minutes not seconds away
you must take action to protect yourself
[Music]
okay
everybody stay calm it's probably just a
drill
[Music]
damn i mean it's like john wick
the production
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
if you can help others without putting
yourself i mean in other countries
playing this
i mean they just go what a barbaric like
society it's hilarious yeah
uh i want to get to the part with the
cops because they're like don't they uh
about how to approach the police so they
don't shoot you the one thing i like
about this video so far is they've not
pretended the cops are gonna help you
like that is what i like right like
there's actually been no like wait for
the cops or the cops are on their way
the only thing they've said is the cops
are minutes not seconds away and i think
they should also follow that up with
they may not even come in
the cops may choose to stand outside for
an hour so don't even think they'll
necessarily help you
yeah because you're supposed to assist
the injured like you're she's doing well
huh she just got shot she's like oh boy
if you can't move safely i wonder why
she didn't book any other roles or
confined areas can you go back to that
please yeah i wonder why she didn't book
any other roles she got she just got
shot watch this if you can help others
without putting yourself in unnecessary
danger
do something okay
what's
then secure the location
it is weird they tell you to do
everything you secure the location
well no i like that no this is at least
honest they're not telling you the cops
are coming to help you
oh my gosh there's somebody shooting
that girl smiled the black girl smiles
over it really go back to that
no no
she goes in because there's so much
shooting the black girl literally smiles
watch this there's somebody shooting
look at the black house
that white [ __ ] tongue got shot
once it's hilarious that's great they
didn't edit that that's amazing watch
this
she smiles amazing she literally smiled
you'd think that they were you'd think
the director would be like no no you're
upset about this right right
you're upset this development bothers
you
no but i mean go back one more time yeah
the girl literally
smiles
this girl comes in because there's
somebody shooting and this girl
literally smiles
oh my god there's somebody shooting
everybody stay calm
remember i mean she's smiling like
flirtatious corner
funny
he's like oh this could be a fun day
drywall won't stop a bullet
but there are steps to take to stay safe
okay
we'll barricade the doors turn off the
lights move away from any windows and
silence your cell phone
move desks or anything just block it
a modern emergency bag can include a
first aid kit gloves emergency plans for
the building and casualty cards to alert
first responders to any wounded victims
the cops are still not here it's two
hours later situations are over in 10 to
15 minutes attention lakewood it's
called threes neither at 2 45 gsb 417
it's going to be at alexander
divaldi was like two days
law enforcement's first responsibility
when entering an active shooter
situation is to stop the suspect not to
render aid to the victims
medical teams will enter the scene as
soon as the suspect is no longer a
threat or is confirmed in another
location
silence any cell phones and remain quiet
do not alert the shooter to your
presence
uh oh
you see just like a snapchat
notification go off
[Laughter]
the morbidly obese cops are here look
how fat the cops are go back to that
go back to how fat the cops are they're
very fat finally after 15 minutes the
fattest cops you've ever seen will
arrive
here they come
here they are
the piglets are here
sheriff's department is there anyone
inside
yes
so this is this i don't even understand
just hang tight
what is that you're supposed to like
show law enforcement like a red card
it's called the casualty card yeah and
you still don't have one you fill out a
casualty card about who made it and who
didn't and you put it outside the door
what's the problem
what's the problem
all right
well folks that's the episode for this
week lot going on stay safe out there
try to
keep yourself uh healthy and wealthy
um
it's
it's difficult
try to keep yourself from getting shot
you know i don't know what to tell you
it's been uh
it's been uh kind of violent out there
uh but the summer i don't think has been
that bad with crime i think it's been
i haven't heard anything so
um you know just try to
and you know if you go down there to
mexico leave them alone
stop stop setting up don't go down there
and set up life coaching businesses
go and have some tequila and get out of
there
what are you doing
you're not
timdillacomedy.com
for tickets to the shows that we have
uh we will see everybody on patreon and
then next week thank you